All right. So this is
philosophy one 76, uh,
the classes on death.
My name is Shelly Kagan,
and the very first thing I want to do
is to invite you to call me Shelly.
Uh, that is, uh, you know,
we meet on the street,
you come talk to me during office hours.
He asked some question.
Shelley's the name that I respond to,
I will eventually respond
to professor Kagan. Uh,
but the synapsis take a bit longer,
uh, for that. It's not the name.
I immediately recognize. Uh, I
have found that over the years,
fewer and fewer students feel comfortable
calling me. Shelly, when I was young,
it seemed to work. Now
I'm gray and August. Uh,
but as Eddie's Shelly,
if you're comfortable with it,
it's the name that that I prefer
to be called by. Now. As I say,
this is a class on death. Uh,
but it's a philosophy class.
And what that means is that the set of
topics that we're going to be talking
about in this class are not
identical to the topics that, uh,
other classes on death might try to cover.
So the first thing I want to do is say
something about the things we won't be
talking about that you might reasonably
expect or hope that a class on deck one
talk about.
So that if this is not the
class you were looking for,
you still have time to go
check out some other class.
So here are some things that you know,
a class on death could cover
that we won't talk about.
And what I primarily have in mind are
sort of psychological and sociological
questions about the nature of
death or the phenomenon of death.
And so a class on death, well, uh,
have a discussion of the process of dying
and coming to reconcile yourself with
the fact that you're going to die.
Some of you may know about, uh,
Elizabeth Kubler Ross's discussion of
the so-called five stages of dying.
There's denial and then there's anger.
And then there's bargaining.
I'd actually remember the five stages.
We're not going to talk about, uh,
about that.
Similarly,
we're not going to talk about the funeral
industry in America and how it rips
off people in which it does rips off
people in their moments of grief and
weakness and overcharges them for,
for the various things that it office.
We're not going to talk about that.
We're not going to talk about, uh,
the process of grieving or bereavement.
We're not going to talk about
a sociological attitudes
that we have towards the
dying, uh, in our culture
and how we tend to, you know,
try to keep the, the, the dying,
uh, hidden from the rest of us.
These are all perfectly important
topics, but they're not, as I say,
topics that we're going to be
talking about in this class.
So what will we talk about?
Well,
the things we'll talk about
are philosophical questions
that arise as we begin
to think about the nature of death.
Like this here's in, in, in broad scope,
half the class is going
to be the first half.
The class is going to be metaphysics.
For those of you who are familiar with
the philosophical piece of jargon and
roughly half the class,
the second half the class is going to be
value theory so that first half of the
class is going to be concerned with
questions about the nature of death.
What happens when we die?
Indeed to get at that question,
the first thing we're going to
have to think about is what are we,
what kind of an entity is
a person in particular?
Do we have souls and for this class,
what I talk about a soul,
what I'm going to mean,
it's sort of a bit of philosophical
jargon isn't going to mean something in
something distinct from our bodies.
Do we have in material souls something
that might survive the death of our body
and if not, what does that
imply about the nature of death?
What kind of an event is death?
What is it for me to survive? What would
it mean for me to survive my death?
What does it mean for me to
survive tonight? That is, you know,
somebody is going to be here lecturing
to your, to the class on Thursday.
Presumably that will be me.
What is it for that person who's there
on Thursday to be the same person as the
person who's sitting here
lecturing to you today?
These are questions about the nature
of personal identity pretty clearly to
think about death and continued
existence and survival.
We have to get clear about the
nature of personal identity.
These sorts of questions will occupy
us for roughly the first half of the
semester and then we'll turn to
value.
Questions is if death is the end,
is death bad?
Now of course most of us are immediately
in strongly inclined to think the death
is bad,
but there are a set of philosophical
puzzles about how death could be bad to
just sort of give you a quick taste.
If after my death I won't exist,
how could anything be bad for me?
How could anything be bad for
something that doesn't exist?
So how could death be bad?
So it's not that the result's going to be,
I'm going to try to convince you
to death isn't bad, but it's,
it takes actually a little bit of work.
Then pin pin down precisely what is it
about death that's bad and how can it be
death? And as a more than one thing
about death that makes it bad,
we'll turn to questions like that.
If death is bad,
then one might wonder is would
the mortality be a good thing?
And that's a question that we'll think
about or more generally we'll worry about
how should the fact that I'm going
to die affect the way I live?
What should I attitude be
towards my mortality? Should I,
uh, uh, should, should I be
afraid of death? For example,
should I despair at the fact
that I'm going to die? Um,
finally we'll turn to
questions about suicide. Uh,
many of us think that given the valuable
and precious thing that life is suicide
and makes no sense, you're throwing away
the only life you ever going to have. Uh,
and so we'll end this semester by thinking
about questions along the lines of
the rationality and morality of suicides.
So roughly speaking,
that's where we're going
first half of the class,
metaphysics second half
of the class value theory.
Next thing I need to explain is this.
There's roughly speaking
two ways to do a class,
especially in introductory class
like this. In approach number one,
you simply lay out the various
positions pro and con and the professor,
uh,
strives to remain neutral,
sort of not tip his hand about what he
holds, that sort of approach. Number one,
and sometimes in my intro classes,
that's the approach that I take,
but the other approach and the one that
I should warn you I'm going to take this
semester in this class
is rather different.
There's a line that I'm
going to be developing,
pushing,
if you will or defending in this class.
That is to say there's a certain set of
views I hold about the issues that we'll
be discussing and what I'm going to try
to do in this class is argue for those
users. Try to convince you
that those views are correct
to help you know sort of ahead of
time quickly what those views are.
I want to start by describing a set of
views that many of you probably believe.
So I'm going to give you a cluster of use.
Logically speaking,
you could believe some of these
things are not all of them,
but here's a set of views that
many of you probably believe in it.
I imagine most of you believe at
least some of these things. So here,
here's the set of common views.
First of all, that we have a soul.
That is to say we're not just bodies,
we're not just lumps of bone and flesh,
but there's a part of us,
perhaps the essential part of us that
is something more than the physical,
the spiritual, immaterial part of
us, which as I say in this class,
we'll call a soul.
So most of us,
most of you probably believe in soul,
certainly most people in America
believe in some sort of immaterial soul.
And given this existence
of this immaterial soul,
it's a possibility,
indeed a fair likelihood that
we will survive our deaths.
The death will be the, you know,
the destruction of my body,
but my soul is in material.
And so my soul can continue
to exist after my death.
And whether or not you
actually believe in a soul,
you hope that there's a soul,
uh,
so that there'll be this
serious possibility of
surviving your death because
death is not only bad but so horrible
that what we would like to have happen is
we would like to live forever.
And so armed with a soul as it were,
there's at least the
possibility of immortality in
mortality would be wonderful.
That's what we hope is the case. Uh,
whether or not we know that it's the case,
the mortality, it would be wonderful.
That's why death so bad, it robs us of,
of immortality. And if,
if there is no soul,
if death is the end, if there's, if
there is no immortality, this is such an,
if there is no immortality,
this is such an overwhelming
Lee bad thing that the only,
the obvious reaction,
the natural reaction,
the universal reaction is to face the
prospect of death with a fear and despair.
And,
uh,
as I mentioned earlier than death is so
horrible and life is so wonderful that
it could never make
sense to throw it away.
And so suicide is both immoral on
the one hand and never make sense.
It's always irrational, uh, as well. In
addition, all right. That, that as I say,
as I think a common set of views about
the nature of death and what I'm going to
be doing,
what I'm going to be arguing in this
class is that that set of views is pretty
much mistaken from beginning to end.
Uh,
and so I'm going to try to
convince you that, you know,
there is no soul in mortality,
would not be a good thing.
Fear of death isn't actually
inappropriate. Uh, response to death.
Suicide under certain circumstances
might be rationally, morally justified.
As I say,
they're common picture is pretty
much mistaken from start to end.
That's at least my goal.
That's, that's my aim.
That's what I'm going to be doing now.
Since of course I believe the views I
believe and I hope at the end of the
semester you'll agree with me because I
think they're true and I hope you'll end
up believing the truth.
But I shouldn't say that.
The crucial point isn't
for you to agree with me.
The crucial point is for you to think
for yourself and so what I'm really doing
is inviting you to take a good cold,
hard look at death and to face it and
think about it in a way that most of us
don't do.
If you at the end of the semester haven't
agreed with me about this particular
claim of that particular claim,
so be it. I'll be content,
I won't be completely content,
but I'll be at least largely content as,
as you've really thought through the
arguments on each side of these various
issues. Carry. Maybe it would be a good
time for the past around the syllabus.
Alright,
next introductory remark.
Let a lot of today's talk's going to
be devoted to business. I'll get to a,
if time permits,
some philosophy at the end.
I want to make you one more remark about
what I'll be doing in terms of this
class. This class, as I say,
it's a philosophy class.
We'll basically be sitting here thinking
about what we can know or make sense of
with regard to death using our,
you know,
our reasoning capacities.
We'll,
we'll be trying to think about death
from a rational standpoint. Um,
one kind of evidence or one
kind of argument that we
won't be making use of here
is appeal to religious authority.
So some of you may believe in,
for example,
the existence of an afterlife may believe
you're going to survive your death. Uh,
you may believe in immortality because
that's what your church teaches you. And,
and that's fine.
It's not my purpose or intention here to
try to argue you out of your religious
beliefs or to argue against
your religious beliefs.
All I'm going to ask is that we not appeal
to such religious arguments appeal to
revelation or the authority of the Bible
or what have you in the course of this
argument, of course, of
this class, if you want to,
you could think of this class
as one big hypothetical.
What conclusions would we come to about
the nature of death if we had to think
about it from a secular perspective,
making use of only our own reasoning as
opposed to a whatever answers we might
be given by divine revealed authority.
Those of you who believe in divine
revealed authority, uh, you know,
that's a debate for another day.
It's not a debate that we're going to be
engaged in here, uh, in this semester.
And similarly,
although I'm not going to ask you in
your discussion sections to hide your
religious views, uh,
you'll be asked, you know,
in the course of defending them to,
to give reasons that would make sense to,
you know, to all of us. All right.
Uh, that's my way of sort of where the
class is going. Let me now turn to uh,
some discussion about the requirements
of the class grades and so forth and so
on.
The syllabus is going around the class.
Almost all of you have it at this point
that this all does doesn't really say a
whole lot. I've already given you an
overview of what topics we'll be going to.
The,
the crucial point about the syllabus is
that it indicates what reading you need
to have done for any given week.
Now,
I've done my to peg the readings to
where I will be on that week's lectures,
but I don't lecture with
lecture notes for the most part.
Sometimes they take a little bit
longer than I anticipated. Actually.
I often take a little bit longer
than I anticipated. No doubt.
At some point I'll fall behind. At some
point they may rush to catch up ahead.
It won't always be the case that the
readings will exactly coincide with where
the lectures are at.
Nonetheless,
in any given week for
the start of that week,
you should have done the readings
that are listed for that week.
The readings on the syllabus,
simply say the author, you know,
and there's, there's a couple
of books that are available.
A at the bookstore there are a larger
packet of readings that's available as a
course pack at Tycho's. Uh, and
so for any given week, you know,
you can find the reading one or two cases,
uh,
maybe just one actually where I've got
more than one article by the given author,
I've given the,
the title of the article as well shouldn't
be difficult to locate the reading
for any given week.
The format of the class of course is
a familiar and straight forward one.
I'll be sitting here lecturing,
uh, twice a week. This time,
10 30 to 11,
20.
Once a week you will break
up into discussion sections,
the discussion sections,
we'll meet for 50 minutes.
You of course will have a single time.
Each one of you will have a single time.
That will be different times.
The discussion sections meet for this
for the first time that the philosophy
apartment has just switched over
to the online discussion section.
Registration System.
I'm not 100% certain how that works.
I've not used it before.
I take it.
The idea is something like this right now,
if you were to shop the class,
you could find the tentative list of
discussion section days and times,
so it'd be sure to find some
time that works for you.
You can't actually register for any of
those discussions section times yet,
but as of I think next week when you're
able to begin your online registration,
you will be able to register for any
discussion section that still has a slot,
still has a space open in it.
In fact,
you won't be able to
finalize your discussion.
You won't be able to finalize your
registration for your courses until you've
actually signed up for an available
slot once you have registered.
Uh, if some other slots become available
that weren't previously available,
I gather you'll be sent some sort of email
by the system in case some other time
would be better for you. You can put
yourself on waiting lists and so forth.
It sounds pretty good on paper.
Maybe the law works smoothly.
I've never been through it before.
I hope we won't have any problems,
but right now what you want to make
sure is that there is a time that's
available.
I mean right now all the times available,
but that there is a time that works
for you because if you can't find a
discussion section that works for you,
you won't be able to take this course.
Any questions about that?
Any questions?
I should actually ask any questions
about anything that I've asked or said so
far up to this point.
Let me make a remark about
questions, which is, Oh yeah,
today's mostly business.
Hopefully it will be
fairly straight forward,
but both today and throughout the
entire semester as I'm lecturing,
I want to invite you to
jump in with questions.
We'll jump into a bit of an exaggeration.
I don't want to just start talking,
but you know, raise your hand. You know,
if I'm saying something
that you don't understand,
that chances are pretty good that there's
25 or 50 other students in the class
who don't understand it either.
I'm just not being clear and
so I want to welcome you.
I really want to invite you whenever you
got some reactions to the things that
I'm saying, you know, Shelly know, raise
your hand. I'll call on you. Say, shall,
I didn't really understand what
you were saying about the soul.
Could you please explain that again or
for that matter if you've got some quick
reactions or thoughts or responses to
the arguments that I'm laying out and you
want to share them with
the class as a whole,
then very much I want to
invite you to do this.
Now this class is too big for us
to have some, you know, close,
intimate,
a conversation between the 150 hours,
180 however many students there are here.
That's not going to happen.
Yeah.
But you know,
the,
the chance for detailed discussion
in the discussion section,
I mean that's where that should happen.
But still there is a chance for, you know,
brief reactions and definitely a chance
for questions and I very much want to
invite you to do that.
So if at any point you've got something
you want to ask about or some two bits
you want to add, raise your hand,
wiggle it around, make sure I see you.
I may want to finish that
particular point that I'm making,
but I'll try to come back to
you and I'll then you know,
raise your question and if I remember
at least I will repeat the question out
loud. Uh, so that everybody can hear it.
Also want to say that I will try to
have the practice of after class ends.
If you want to continue the discussion,
you have some questions that
occurred to you towards the end.
We didn't have a chance to share
them with the class as a whole.
I will on a normal day meet outside and
continue to talk with however many of
you want to do that until
you're done. Uh, so I mean,
I just love talking about
this stuff. Uh, and you know,
so I welcome you to
come to my office hours.
I invite you to ask questions in class
or if you prefer after class as well.
And again,
any questions about any of that?
Yeah,
one on my office hours.
That's a great question and I
don't know the answer to it on fee.
I haven't planned them yet on Thursday.
Start the class by asking me that and
I'll give you an answer. All right.
Um, other bits of business. I
should say something about grades.
Now, many of you may have
heard, many of you may know,
and if you don't already know this,
I should warn you that I have a reputation
around Yale as being a harsh grader.
I know this is true.
That is,
I know I have the reputation both
because I periodically and my student
evaluations get told I'm one of Yale's
harsher graders, harder graders.
And because every now and
then the Yale Daily News,
we'll have an article about grade
inflation on the law. Always ask me, well,
you know,
professor Kagan is somebody,
once there was a story on grade inflation
that the Aal Daily News began by
saying,
as Shelly Kagan parentheses known at
Yale is one of the hardest graders,
closed parentheses.
So I know I've got at least the
reputation of being a hard grader. Uh,
I don't actually know
whether it's deserved or not
because Yale does not publish
a information about what the
grading averages are. You know,
at other schools I've
taught at, uh, there's been
information along the lines of,
well,
the typical grade and an introductory
course in the humanities is such and such.
Uh, shortly after I came
here to Yale, uh, and I said,
realizing that people were
thought it was a harder,
greater than than most
other Yale professors. Uh,
I called the administration and asked,
do you have this sort of information?
And the answer is yes. Will you
give it to me? The answer was no.
Uh, they don't share this
information with the Yale Faculty.
Seems odd that the,
the,
the explanation courts actually
isn't that hard to come by.
The worry is that those of us who
are harder graders than average,
if the information war published would
feel guilty and sort of ease up on our
grading.
But those who are easier graders than
average will never feel guilty and toughen
up. And so the result would
be a constant push up, uh,
with the grades anyway. So I don't know
for a certainty that I'm a harder grader,
but I believe that it's the case based
on reactions I get when I give the speech
that I'm about to give. Okay. So
when I open the blue book,
the Yale guideline, you know,
th th th th the Yale catalog,
it's got a page, as you all know,
where it says what grades,
what letter grades mean at Yale.
I didn't actually bring it this year.
Sometimes I do,
but I've got it pretty much
memorized. Uh, it says, for example,
next to each letter grade, you
know what it means. B for example,
means good.
A means excellence seeming satisfactory
or a d is passing. F is failing being,
I'll start with B. B means good. Now,
quite crucial question then
is what does good mean?
I take good to mean good.
Consequently,
if you want to write a good paper for me,
that would get a B.
And when you get a B from me,
and I say me,
this is the royal me, you know? Uh,
because I won't actually be
grading your papers. Uh, your,
your papers will be graded
by a small army of tas,
but they will grade under my supervision.
And in keeping with the standards that
I asked them, uh, to, to grade myself.
So when you're pissed off about your
grades, the person to take it up with it,
well, I'll take it up with
them, but, but you know,
then surely you want to take it up with
me. So when you get it right be from us,
B doesn't mean what a
piece of crap B means.
Good job.
And so you shouldn't be pleased to get
a B because it meant you were doing good
work and it's not easy to do good
work in philosophy a means excellent.
Now,
excellent does not mean publishable.
Excellent does not mean you are
God's gift to philosophy. Right?
And so it's crucial to understand.
It doesn't mean if the only way you're
going to get an a is to be God's gift to
philosophy.
A's mean excellent work for
a first class in philosophy.
This is an introductory class.
It does not presuppose any
background in philosophy.
Well to get an a,
you've got to show some
flair for the subject.
You've got to show not only have you
sort of understood the ideas and they've
been put forward and the readings,
uh, and in the lectures and so forth,
but you see how to sort of
put them together in a paper
in a way that shows you
got some aptitude here. You did it
in a way that made us take note.
That's what we try to
reserve a [inaudible] for.
Some of you will end up getting
A's if not at the beginning.
By the end of the semester,
many of you will end up getting B's.
If not at the beginning.
By the end of the semester,
many of you will not
start out doing good work.
Many of you,
we'll start out doing satisfactory work
or truth be told less than satisfactory
work.
Now look,
I was an undergraduate once and I
know what it is to write a typical
undergraduate paper.
You sit down the night before
and you had a couple of ideas.
You thought about it maybe for a half
an hour at Ba and you meant to get to it
sooner,
but you had a lot of other things to do
and you throw it off in a couple hours
and you know,
maybe stay up late and you know it's not
the worst thing you ever wrote and it's
not the best thing he ever wrote.
And it has a couple of Nice ideas,
but maybe it could be better.
It's sort of a satisfactory job.
Well Yale says satisfactory
means c and so many of you,
we'll start off the semester
writing that kind of paper.
And the fact of the matter is some of you,
we'll start off writing worst papers
than that because writing a philosophy
paper is a difficult thing
to learn how to do. It's not,
it's exercising a set of muscles that a
lot of you have not spent a lot of time
exercising. Now the thought is that you
haven't spent any time doing it. I mean,
you've had bull sessions, right, with
your high school friends or, and you know,
your college dorm or what have you,
but you haven't done it with the kind of
discipline and rigor that we're looking
for here.
And so like anything else,
it's a skill that gets
better with practice and,
but what that means of course,
is you won't do as well at the beginning
as you're likely to be doing toward the
end.
Some of you unfortunately,
won't do very good jobs at the beginning.
And my tas,
I'll encourage them to be
prepared to give, you know, Ds,
if the vices of the paper
significantly outweigh the virtues,
that's a d if devices very significantly
outweigh whatever virtues are,
that's some kind of an f.
So the fact of the matter is many of you
in your initial papers will get lower
grades than you've probably
ever gotten before in your life.
Wanted to warn you about that.
Now I say this not so much to
depress the hell out of you,
but hey,
partly to warn you and B to make it
clear that I believe that it's a skill
writing philosophy.
Good philosophy paper is a skill and you
can get better at it and consequently
most of you will get better at it. And
so let me make the follow me to remark.
Look officially each paper you
have three five page papers.
Each paper is worth 25%
of your grade officially,
but the remaining 25% of his discussion
section, we'll get to that in a minute.
Officially 25% of your grade
for each of the three papers,
but if over the course of
the semester you get better,
then we will give at the end of the
semester when we're figuring out your
semester grade,
we'll give the later stronger papers
more than their official weight.
For many of you,
the first paper will be clearly the
worst paper you write and then we'll just
throw that great away,
give greater weight to
the second third paper.
The third paper is a stronger still
we'll get even more weight to the third
paper.
There is no formula here.
Great deal depends on the overall pattern,
what uta tells me about how you've
done over the course of the semester,
but this policy of giving greater weight
if you show improvement is something
that most of you will benefit from.
And so if you end up not doing well,
the moral of the story is not to go
running off and dropping the class,
but to figure out what you did right,
what you didn't do right,
how to make the second paper better and
then the third paper stronger again.
And if you do show improvement,
that will vary significantly influence
and emerge in terms of the impact it has
on your overall semester grade.
Because of this policy,
I don't actually know when all is said
and done are there at the end of the
semester, I'm any harder, you know,
whether I depart from the average or not.
Let me quickly mention,
here's a fairly typical grade distribution
for the overall grades of this.
At the end of the semester,
roughly 25% of you are likely to end up
with some kind of an a at the end of the
semester,
50 55% of you are so are likely
to end up with some kind of uh,
be 2020 5% of you might
end up with some sort of a,
see sometimes there's a couple of
percent that end up worse than that.
Unsurprisingly,
you've got the ability to do decent work
in this class and most of you have the
ability to do good work and some
of you have a fair chunk of,
you have the ability to do excellent
work though it may take some work on your
part to get to that point. Last thing
I should say about the grades is,
look, why do I do this? It's really,
I try to do it as a
sign of respect for you.
I know that may seem like a surprising
to say what I've just sort of gone on my
little gleeful Amanda, but I'm going to
fail all of you. But I mean it's, it's,
it's worth my saying, you
know, you guys are so smart,
you're so talented.
You've gotten so far on your ability that
many of you have learned to coast and
it's not doing you any kind of
service to let you continue coasting.
My goal here is to be honest with you,
right? Say, look, you're smart enough,
probably most of you to Paul,
some sort of be without a lot of,
without breaking into a sweat, at least
not a significant sweat. So be it.
But it's just lying to you to pretend
that that's excellence in philosophy.
And so what I want to do in this class
is be honest with you and tell you you've
really done work here to
be extraordinarily proud
of yourself versus yeah,
you've done something okay or hook, you
done good work. Admittedly it's not great,
but you've done good work. All right,
that's 75% of your grade is the papers.
The remaining 25% of your grade
is based on discussion section.
Now that's a lot of your grade
to turn on discussion section.
And so the first thing I need
to tell you is I really mean it.
If you blow off discussion section,
your grade will suffer.
So it's worth knowing in a general way.
What do you need to do to earn a good
grade and discussion section and hearing
the answer is perhaps the obvious one.
You need to participate,
you need to come to discussion sections.
Having thought about the lectures,
having done the readings,
having thought about the questions
that they raise and you need to come to
discussion section.
Then prepared to discuss
this week's set of issues.
You need to listen to what your classmates
are saying and say why you disagree
with them and not just that you disagree
with him but to raise an objection or
why you agree with them and when somebody
else and attacks them and say, look,
I think that what John was saying was
a good point and here's how I think he
should have defended his
position or what have you.
You need to engage in
philosophical discussion.
If you're not participating
in discussion section,
you're not doing what the section is.
Therefore,
philosophers love to talk and we love
to argue and the way to get better at
thinking about philosophy is
by talking about philosophy.
And so I'm putting my money where
my mouth is. I'm saying, look, yeah,
that's an important part of the class.
So important that it's going to
be worth 25% of your grade. Again,
it doesn't mean this is slightly
different from the papers.
It doesn't mean that you've got to be
brilliant philosophically to get an a
rather you got to be a wonderful class
citizen to get an a for discussion
sections. And so as I put it, in fact,
I think I put it this way in the
syllabus sort of participation and here,
I mean sort of, you know, respectful
participation, not hogging the limelight,
but no participation
can improve your grade,
but it won't lower your grade non
participation or not being there.
That will lower your participation grade.
Again, any questions about any of that?
All right, so you know, I'm sorry to have
this sort of the long gloom and doom,
but it seems that it's only fair to
sort of let you know what you're getting
into. One other remark about
the discussion sections,
the way I think of it is
like the conversation hour
for your foreign language
class. Many, how many of you have
had a philosophy class before?
Look, thanks. You know, maybe
15% of you, maybe 20% of you,
most of you have not. All right?
That's pretty normal, right?
Don't go into discussion section
thinking, oh, I can't talk.
I don't have any background in philosophy.
I've never done this sort of thing before.
That's true for most of you.
The way you get better
is by talking philosophy.
Alright,
next remark.
I guess this is sort of just one last
connection with God. Your grades.
This is an intro philosophy class.
The crucial point about intro is it
means FirstClass in philosophy doesn't
presuppose any background in philosophy.
It doesn't necessarily mean easy.
Some of this material for some of you
is going to be very, very difficult.
And although the number of pages that
you'll have to read are not, you know,
there's not a lot, you know, probably
typical week, 50 pages, maybe less.
It's for many of you,
you got to find it dense material and
although I don't really have the fantasy
that many of you will read this stuff
twice if you had the time to do it,
that would be a wonderful thing to do.
Philosophy is hard stuff to read.
Other remark about this being an intro
intro classes that it's introductory in
that the issues that we're talking about,
our kind of first run through every
single thing that we discuss here could be
pursued at greater depth.
So for example,
will spend whatever it is maybe a week
and a half talking about the nature of
personal identity,
two weeks,
but one could easily spend an entire
semester thinking about that question
alone.
So don't come away thinking that whatever
it is that we've talked about here in
lectures,
the last word on the subject rather
it's something more like first words.
Actually one of the work
about what worried about um,
the readings and the lectures.
With one exception I won't be spending
very much time talking about the
readings. The exception is Plato
where I'll spend a lecture,
maybe two lectures trying to
reconstruct Plato's central arguments,
at least the arguments
relevant to our class.
It will be really one to Plato's
dialogues, but for the most part,
although I'll occasionally
periodically refer to the readings,
I won't spend a lot of time talking
about the views in the readings,
the readings you should think of
as complimentary to my lectures.
The idea is that there's more to say
than what I've said and you'll find some
more of what there is to say in the
readings or there may be positions that I
mentioned but I don't develop cause
I'm not perhaps sympathetic to them.
And you might find somebody who is
sympathetic to them, developing them,
developing them in the readings.
The readings are a crucial
component of the class.
You won't get everything
you need simply by doing,
by coming to the lectures.
But equally the case that the views
that be developing and the lectures are,
although not necessarily unique to me,
aren't all laid out in the readings.
You won't get everything I'm
talking about in the lectures.
If all you do is the readings.
They're both parts of the class.
All right. I want to end by, uh,
we were not close to MD,
but the last time I'm going to do is
read aloud some student evaluations.
I have found over the years
that some students like me,
some students don't like me.
I don't know how to make this point any
clear then to share with you a sampling
of the uh, student evaluations. These
are not actually from last spring,
but their typical enough that I was
too lazy to make some new quotes.
Oh one. So these are actual quotes
from former actual students. One,
the lecturers were clear and
followed a very logical order to,
I thought the class was not
always organized. Three,
I thought it was a very well organized
class for overall I was unsatisfied with
this course.
Few substantive conclusions were reached.
Five along the same vein.
I think he should avoid saying at
the end of each segment of the class,
ultimately you'll have to decide
what to think for yourself.
I should end the class by saying
you will blow the, okay. I actually,
I started the class by saying that you
will believe what I believe six it might
be improved by presenting other
views better and more objectively.
Since Kagan always ended up particular
line of reasoning by defeating the
argument.
If he didn't agree with it,
he could be a bit more unbiased
and tolerant of other perspectives.
Seven lectures where sometimes repetitive
or obvious but occasionally they
provided new insights.
Eight,
I know that some felt the pace of
the arguments was a little slow,
but I felt this was generally necessary
not only for the on philosophy savvy
population but also to cover our points.
Nine extremely thorough and thoughtful,
receptive to questions.
Brilliant. I like that
one. Often longwinded
10 he does go wrong and her on
the same idea a number of times,
which does cut down on the notes for the
class, but it can get a little boring.
11 though. I've heard students
say he often repeats himself.
I think this is a merit in a philosophy
course in which arguments and thoughts
can quickly become confusing.
12 Shelly Kagan is a fabulous,
resourceful,
honorly convincing lecturer.
13 he would work through arguments
right in front of him. This one,
this what actually I like this one going.
I think this is what at least aimed to
be inside my head. Here's what I'm doing.
13 he would work through
arguments right in front of us,
which then helped me work
through them on my own.
14 Shelly is an incredibly
dynamic lecturer.
15 he's just in his own world,
babbling on and on.
I zone out with regularity.
16 I have to say that's Shelly Kagan is
probably the best lecture I had in my
four years at Yale.
17 he's the type of teacher
you either love or hate.
Now,
that's pretty clearly true.
I wish there were some easy litmus test
that I could just give you so you'd know
which of you would be making
a mistake taking this class.
I don't know how to give it to
you. Next topic, grades one,
he tried to intimidate us too much with
his promise of impossible grading so
that everyone took the class credit d
fail when we all probably ended up with
A's or B's because grading was not hard
to I recommended but only credit d fail.
Professor Kagan is harsh with grading
three when Shelly says he's the harshest
grader on campus,
he isn't lying.
I was consistently surprised
by how poorly I did on papers.
The standards in this class are just
different from all other classes.
For Kagan's reputation as a
harsh grader is unfounded.
If you put in the effort, the grade
will reflect that so that does that.
You know that settles the question on
my a harsh grader, not now. As you know,
the last question for the evaluations
or should you take the class or not,
would you recommend it to somebody else?
One,
I believe this class is one of the most
mind opening experiences of my life to,
no,
it's a waste of a course.
Three it gets kind of depressing at times,
but I suppose that's due to
the nature of the subject
for this course stands out as one of
the more unique and stimulating courses.
I've taken it Yale five excellent class.
It made me think about life
and death in a new way.
What more can you ask for from a
class six I would not recommend it.
The class just seemed to be a platform
for Kagan to throw out random ideas and
the students were never required
to engage in any thought. Well,
that clears that up. Let me end with
a couple of other quick remarks.
One, these are some of my all time
favorites from previous years.
One not doing the reading
didn't hurt me at all.
Now I of course these
are anonymous comments.
I don't know who wrote this comment,
but I do know this.
Whoever wrote this remark is an idiot.
Whoever wrote this or mark seems to be
under the impression that the point of
being at Yale is to spend $40,000 a
year of your parents' money and get away
with learning as little as possible.
Well for those of you who want to try it,
you probably could pass this class and
maybe even get an okay grade without
doing the readings.
There's no final exam,
but still it's crucial to understand.
Doing the readings is an important part
of learning what this course has to
offer.
Different quote.
Cagan is a self righteous little man.
Got To tell Ya. That been about
being little at really hurts.
Another one. Great course, wonderful
professor, fascinating subjects.
It's the deepest thinking I've
done in my life. Final quote,
this class taught me how to think
more than any other at Yale.
I don't know whether I pull it off pretty
obviously for a number of students.
I don't manage to pull it off,
but that's at least what my aim is.
I'm trying to help you think.
I welcome you and I hope
you'll be back on Thursday.